Dalam bab ini kita akan terokai
macam mana komputer kuantum dan klasik
bekerjasama untuk selesaikan salah satu cabaran paling penting
dalam sains iaitu menganggar tenaga molekul dan bahan dengan tepat
kita boleh capai ini
dengan guna quantum circuit
untuk jana sampel contoh
yang kemudian akan diproses
dan didiagonalkan oleh beberapa algoritma
dalam keluarga rutin ini
seperti SQV dan SKG dan ada satu kursus penuh di
platform IBM Quantum yang didedikasikan
untuk mereka dan kaedah-kaedah berkaitan
untuk tujuan kita dalam bahagian ini
penerangan akan dibuat ringkas
tak kira sama ada kamu guna SQV atau SKG
matlamat kamu ialah nak cari eigen vector
dan eigen value bagi matriks Hamiltonian
matriks ini mungkin huraikan tenaga sesuatu sistem fizik
atau kimia tapi kerangka yang sama
boleh tangani banyak jenis masalah lain
seperti logistik kadang-kadang
matriks-matriks ini sangat besar
jadi mengurangkan dimensi
matriks sambil kekalkan ciri-ciri penting
keadaan dasar
boleh jadi sangat bernilai itulah matlamat dalam SQV
kita guna komputer kuantum untuk jana subruang yang berguna
satu yang mengandungi keadaan dasar
kita boleh projektkan matriks Hamiltonian kita
ke atas subruang tu yang tinggalkan kita
dengan matriks kecil yang akan jadi
lebih mudah untuk didiagonalkan
guna pengkomputeran klasik berprestasi tinggi kita buat ini
dengan sediakan keadaan kuantum percubaan
yang selalu dipanggil ansatz
dan buat pengukuran untuk sampel ansatz tu
dalam asas pengiraan yang beri kita
subruang sampel dalam asas pengiraan
tapi apa yang betul-betul kita nak cari
ialah keadaan dasar sebenar apa
kalau subruang sampel kita tak mengandungi
semua komponen yang diperlukan
kalau kita pilih ansatz yang lebih baik
kita mungkin dapat anggaran keadaan dasar yang lebih baik
itu bawa kita ke sample-based
Krylov quantum diagonalization atau SKUDY dalam SKUDY
kita mulakan dengan ansatz
macam sebelum tapi kemudian kita guna beberapa quantum gate yang anggarkann
evolusi masa sebuah sistem fizikal
boleh ditunjukkan bahawa dengan beberapa andaian
ini membawa kepada jaminan pada pertindihan antara evolusi masa
ansatz dan keadaan dasar sebenar
kedua-dua algoritma ini bermula dengan matriks Hamiltonian
yang sangat besar cara kerjanya agak berbeza
tapi dalam kedua-dua kes bahagian kuantum algoritma menghasilkan
subruang yang membolehkan kita mengecilkan matriks kita
di mana kita harap kekalkan ciri-ciri utama keadaan dasar
jadi di mana pengkomputeran klasik berprestasi tinggi masuk
untuk Hamiltonian yang paling besar
dan untuk anggaran paling tepat bagi keadaan dasar
walaupun matriks yang diprojekkan ini boleh jadi agak besar
oleh itu memanfaatkan keupayaan komputer klasik yang lebih berkuasa
boleh bantu kita bukan sahaja
dapat hasil yang lebih baik
malah dengan membenarkan kita tangani masalah yang lebih besar
untuk gabungkan semuanya
kita boleh wakili algoritma sample-based
sebagai gabungan model pengaturcaraan berbeza
pada satu set sumber heterogen
contohnya kita boleh wakili algoritma kita
sebagai aliran kerja tugas di mana kita ada satu tugas
untuk penyediaan quantum circuit yang bertindih
dengan keadaan sasaran kita diikuti oleh satu tugas
untuk transpilation yang hanya perlukan sumber klasik
untuk dilaksanakan seterusnya akan ada tugas
yang guna primitif untuk jalankan quantum circuit kita
yang jelasnya
dan kemudian akan ada tugas post-processing yang sendirinya
mungkin satu algoritma diagonalization selari
yang berjalan pada beberapa nod
selain itu kita mungkin nak jalankan
salah satu algoritma tu banyak kali
sambil kita ubah ansatz kita
atau jalankan semuanya sepenuhnya secara selari
dengan populasi yang berbeza
sekarang jom kita gabungkan semuanya dengan SKUDY
dalam kod macam ni ini semua fail tugas kita
dan ini semua fail submission kita
dalam tugas mapping kita sediakan circuit.
Dalam langkah optimisation kita jalankan circuit dengan cara terbaik.
Dalam tugas execution kita sampel bistrik
daripada keadaan yang disediakan oleh
ISA circuit kita.
Yang kita dapat daripada langkah sebelumnya
dan kita buat post-processing kita.
Jadi sekarang kita dah sedia nak submit
aliran kerja SKUDY kita.
Macam yang boleh kamu nampak semua berjalan dalam urutan
dengan kebergantungan jom kita tunggu
keputusan dan kita boleh semak fail output kita.
Ini fail output langkah optimisation
di mana kita ada ISA circuit kita.
Dan jom kita semak akhir sekali
jadual kita.
Daripada jadual.
Dan itulah dia untuk demonstrasi ringkas aliran kerja SKUDY
semua kod akan tersedia dalam bahagian teks
atau dalam penerangan di bawah
dan itulah dia kita dah jalankan beberapa
konsep dan contoh yang boleh bantu kamu mulakan dengan
pengurusan program hibrid kompleks tentulah
kalau kamu suka ini hanya menyentuh permukaan
semua yang boleh kamu buat dengan gabungan kuantum
dan sumber klasik khusus untuk terokai lebih lanjut
tengok dokumentasi dan tutorial lain
di platform IBM Quantum
dan pastikan tengok sumber yang dikongsi dalam bahagian teks
atau penerangan untuk lebih banyak item
dan perisian terima kasih kerana menonton.
Ya.